citizens of the reject Nation it is me
Tara Erickson alongside
oh spooky
spooky spooky season yet we are watching
Scott Pilgrim Vs the World I have never
seen this movie what about you Gregory
all right here's
yours came out on Blu-ray I rented it a
lot of my first time rewatches as either
I just don't remember or Greg was the
you know a lot back then so when I
started this movie I got maybe 15
minutes in and realized I'm not in the
proper headspace to process this film
and you turned it off I turned it off
and I N that in the movie never went
back and it never went back to that in
the movie Warrior or the two movies I've
done that with oh very different films
I've never just finished them and now
I'm like well let's do it let's finally
watch this movie we're gonna stick to it
no matter what
okay and you guys better not forget
tearing the Bell to subscribe to
subscribe and lastly don't forget if
you're not already a patron you should
become one because you get the full
reaction oh watch along where you get to
sync up with your own copy and watch the
entire Scott Pilgrim versus the world
with me and Gregory which is insane it's
like you're sitting in your house you're
watching it but we're also there with
you let's get into it
[Music]
oh that's neat took a Mario Brothers
thing I believe this is based on a comic
book oh Scott Pilgrim is dating a high
schooler really is she hot
it's the first question you've been out
of high school for like 13 years I'm 22.
that's gross have you even kissed her we
almost held Hance once but then she got
embarrassed so what's her name
knives ciao
what so when do we get to meet her oh
please let it be soon
that's for me oh it's cool little text
hi you promise to be good of course I'll
be good hey nice this is Steven Stills
the talent the talent
wow hey let me get you covered can you
play the drums
yes awesome nice that's Young Neil
hi
hi it just lives there
[Music]
that's right man some sexy ass rock and
rollers
okay and I love him
oh Anna Kendrick I didn't realize
how many times yeah this might be the
only Edgar Wright movie I didn't finish
what I've seen every other one oh yeah
this might be the only one before you
hear some dirty lies from someone else
yes I'm dating a 17 year old
[Music]
wow
[Laughter]
17 years old Scandal that's not true who
told you Wallace duh that gossipy [__]
already Wallace he's so quick it's been
over a year since you got dumped by she
who will not be named so
oh there she is good old Captain Marvel
[Music]
I do not want to be here at all this
girl has boys too this is like
spider-verse before spider verse my cool
gay roommate Wallace Wells hi he's gay
oh do you wanna know who my class is gay
yes does he wear glasses flawless
[Laughter]
here we go
[Music]
God I love the symmetry of these shots
yeah like wow
It's a combination of a fighting game
it's like Mortal Kombat plus dancing wow
oh God he wants her to pay come on Scott
so he just wants the company but doesn't
want the actual intimacy maybe he
doesn't know how well I knew I
personally rocked but I never suspected
that we rocked as a unit so thank you
Knox
I mean you guys are gonna be huge that's
a hell of a transition party Friday or
will you be busy has issues babysitting
oh so I guess the texts are from his
perspective and the atoms is so cool do
you read her blog I'm sorry you were
saying about me I mean I've never gone
out with anyone so talented I like these
transitions I know they're amazing cool
foreign
well they're holding hands so there's
some intimacy for you Greg I mean it's
kind of creepy though isn't it a little
bit worse I would have felt better she
was eight 18.
whoa trippy huh so alone you're not
alone you're just having some idiotic
dream
does that mean we can make out
speaking of new weren't you supposed to
take your fake high school girlfriend to
the library a half hour ago what it's
like six in the morning
[Laughter]
libraries remind me of grade school
that's Mary I love her so much the dream
girl do you know that girl
Scott what
is your girlfriend distracting you
I'll be quiet ER oh oh my God this poor
girl he treats her like such a big [__]
yeah I'm gonna go pee due to boredom
I love the way you shot him he's just
like what there's like a quirky comic
book symmetry to it
everyone right
yeah pretty much you know this one girl
was here like this yes that's Ramona
Flowers
oh my God what I gotta tell you though I
hear that she's a little hardcore
oh wait are we now on the hunt for
Romano flowers while he's in a serious
relationship with knives ciao
nothing hey you know Pac-Man look at his
cup
well Pac-Man was originally called Puck
man they changed it because people would
change scratch out the P turn it into an
F like
oh God
he's doctor
until she laughed that's amazing I hope
she has boyfriend yes I know back in
your yard she's on another level she's
meant dying at her feet she's caught
some Battle Scars dude she sounds like a
complicated woman
complicatedly cool Scott I forbid you
from hitting on Ramona even if you
haven't had a real girlfriend in over a
year
great use of lighting besides I'm not
even sure she did have a big breakup she
keeps mentioning some guy named Gideon
yeah I don't know what it is about that
girl forget it Scott wow the whip snap
dialogue in this movie love it I've
never been so sure about something then
you should break up with your fake high
school girlfriend yeah you're thinking
of juggling two chicks not even wait who
told you Wallace stuff he's not even
conscious
there is like a choreography and a dance
to this movie yeah like you gotta plan
out these shots hardcore yeah it has
come to my attention that we will be
fighting soon my name is Matthew Patel
and I'm fighting soon over what
I feel so bad for this girl yeah
[Music]
he's doing it
he won't he won't do it he doesn't have
the balls the guts I got us a show oh my
gosh when dude he's not exactly the most
likable guy yeah he's not Michael
ceremony yeah
this like apathetic aloof kind of
individual
[Music]
she makes me want to dye my hair hot
pink
[Music]
and get water blades
wow the production design is through the
roof on this you need to sign for this
all right I dreamed that you were
delivering me this package is that weird
it's not weird at all it's not
do you want to hang out sometime get to
know each other I say yes so it's time
for your damn package
yeah
so yeah eight o'clock
so see right I love it what do you do oh
I'm in between jobs at the moment
it's a beautiful shot yeah I think Act
of God is a pretty decent excuse for a
lousy date so this is a day day I think
there's a thingy over here somewhere a
door
oh wow wow getting like a Sunshine Vibes
yeah especially the over the head shot
with the footprints like such a dream
like choices of filmmaking what kind of
tea do you want there's more than one
kind not into her place blueberry
raspberry ginseng sleepy time green tea
green tea with lemon green tea with
lemon and honey liver disaster she's a
tea gal let me get you a blanket that
would actually be awesome
foreign
kind of aura that her yeah yeah dude I'm
changing ah sorry
crazy
yeah that's very warm what is that
oh okay
[Music]
good for you Scott but aren't you still
in a relationship with knives Chow yeah
man what about her teeth I can
not have to
oh dang okay it's going down I changed
my mind I don't wanna have sex with you
girl all right now Pilgrim what this is
nice just this
thank you
that's sweet
damn how do they do those match Cuts
come to the first round of this battle
of the bands thing you have a band yeah
we're terrible please come
sure can I get your number
oh wow girl number
girl number
[Music]
this movie knows how to play with your
senses I'm Stacy okay this is Wallace's
roommate hey this is my boyfriend Jimmy
hey oh and this he's got glasses
[Music]
knives dude
bro
oh man my name is Crash and he's the
boys they have a girl drummer This song
is called I am so sad goes a little
something like this
[Music]
thank you
wow
this is like so cool you see why I had a
hard time keeping up with this
this is a nightmare
we need to play now and Loud okay
oh my goodness
[Music]
the words
these little things they planted are so
funny
to do too
[Music]
consider our fight
pick up
what the [__] is going on
wow what the [__] is happening right now
[Music]
how do they do it
holy junk
foreign
game like foreshadowing this happening I
guess I mean it definitely seems that
there must just be love decipher later
I'm Ramona's first
evil
ex-boyfriend oh it's Ramona that's
bringing all this in first evil what
does that mean her first evil boyfriend
so she's had multiple whoa cool
didn't you get my email explaining the
situation oh he's the Amazon email yeah
sweet
cool
yes
it was football season and for some
reason
all the little jocks wanted me Matthew
was the only non-white non-jock boy in
town the two of us joined forces and we
took them all down is this how their
comic looks
you'll pay for this flowers
if you
oh my God it's also a musical yes what
[Music]
ah my goodness what my demon hipster
chicks
[Music]
whoa how can this be open your eyes
maybe you'll see
[Music]
that's pretty awesome
cool tell your gay friends I said bye
Wallace again
so is this the world they live in or is
it all like from Scott's head good
question if 70 will ex boyfriends seven
evil exes yes and I have to find defeat
defeat there's seven evil axes if we're
going to continue to date pretty much
it's a lot of baggage I invited Ramona
over for dinner tonight so you can't be
here you have to break up with knives
but it's hard
give me the bacon and go do your dirt
while I watch the Lucas Lee Marathon
who's Lucas Lee
it's pretty good skater no there he is
ah I heard there was action in it I
didn't realize it was like a concrete
video game I didn't realize his style
yeah
I wanna do that
I wanted to invite you over for dinner
it's my birthday dinner I think that's a
really bad idea God buddy break up with
her are you even allowed to date outside
your race or whatever
who care and
oh
no oh no we should break up or whatever
really
yeah stranger things
it's not gonna work out
[Music]
I wonder what this screenplay read like
for this how do you communicate all this
they probably were like listen we can't
give you a script we have to give you a
storyboard so you understand from here
on out no girlfriends or girlfriend talk
at practice it's sudden death now okay
okay and Scott seems like a liability
that's right me that's for me hey you're
here
yes like you said oh her hair's blue now
I changed my hair every week and a half
to get used to it okay bye see you guys
tomorrow you're just leaving oh boy dude
this guy is he's not committed
uncommitted to the band it's actually a
really hard roll for Michael Sarah
because he's got to make this [__]
like a feeling yeah make it somewhat
yeah not so
off-putting but she did it without even
making a big deal of it or anything
she's fickle impulsive spontaneous God
what am I gonna do oh what's wrong with
this car
so so insecure are you a man the hell up
you can get the second half base tonight
you think so if you strike out in the
next hour come find me at the castle if
I strike out okay win see you in 60.
it's actually a really good garlic bread
I could honestly eat it for every meal
and get fat no why would I get fat bread
makes you fat bread makes you fat
[Laughter]
Maggie oh God I need a haircut don't I
what I got a bad haircut right before
oh my goodness now I can barely remember
Scott is acutely aware that his last
salon haircut took place exactly 431
days ago three hours before his big
breakup he's been cutting his own hair
ever since oh no
that's a PTSD it's a trigger wouldn't it
what what
why are you wearing that hat I thought
we could go for a walk
I sort of feel like I'm on drugs when
I'm with you not that I do drugs unless
you do drugs in which case I do drugs
all the time
you need some self-approval my friend
did you find the guy who's talking I
think I'm about to oh my goodness
literally is traveling please say that
it cuts to Kieran and Chris making out
[Music]
I was adopted babies
[Applause]
[Music]
you dated a famous guy in ninth grade we
had drama hey this is so bad he just
followed me around you're shocked I'm
talking to you Scott Pilgrim the only
thing keeping me and her apart is the
two minutes it's gonna take to kick your
ass
how's life is
ah hey
hey
[Music]
there's too many ask them how it feels
to always get his sloppy seconds
[Laughter]
whoa Scott is doing pretty good right
now
wow this is awesome how do they shoot
that
whoa oh oh yes awesome
cool they have these camera work is
insane there must be like some Cuts in
some of those zooms when they switch it
now between Michael Sarah and the stunt
double
Mr Lee
that is terrific
cool
the seven evil X's coming to kill you no
let's go
but are you a pretty good skater can you
do a thingy on that rail
it's icy even
killed me into doing a trick like that
yeah there are girls watching
that's there's a little little glimmers
of sound designer amazing
wow
sweet digs
wow that's totally bailed
he just dies yeah I think so hold on I'm
working for sevens you can't say you
didn't see this coming
axes uh
[Music]
hey hey Scott Envy oh [__] been a while
oh the Captain Marvel how are you I'm
not doing so good right now oh she he's
Desiring him now do you have a
girlfriend should I be jealous yes you
should I have this totally awesome
girlfriend who calls me all the time
she's America she's American I'm not
telling you that Ramona I gotta go to a
nice chatting with you wait
like it's like a femme fatale presence
yeah oh hey knives you're outside
it's got here oh you know what
really yeah
foreign
[Music]
look I've had it today can we not do
this right now okay little chicken next
time I'll be deadly serious next time
what never mind
ah I love how colorful the characters
are yeah they're painted so distinctly
so what can I I got you how are you
doing that with your mouth never mind
how I'm doing it so I can just get my
coffee over here
whoa oh I totally understand if you
don't want to hang out anymore I don't
know I want to hang it's I don't think
anything can get in the way of how I
[__]
perfectly compose
your hair's getting shitty yeah
hahaha
I'm jealous you're jealous I'm allowed
you left me for that cocky pretty boy
we're playing these Palace you should
show totally come wow
Clash of demon header doing a secret
show tomorrow night and envy asked us to
open for them no I hate you whoa we're
doing it we gotta get some Buzz going we
need ground swell we need stalkers
oh my God that's so sad
oh you did the fat ass white girl you
know I think you mentioned she was fat
did you go ahead start I mean I didn't
even know there was good music until
like two months ago
Ramona flower stole my scar but I know
how to get him back classical ride shot
what are these women so obsessed with
Scott I don't get it I don't get it
maybe he has a Vibe and you really just
have to be there to feel it
oh I was gonna be here
oh hello
hey who is that girl again Scott dated
her briefly briefly how old is she
this movie could have easily been overly
excessive but it manages to be very
tangible yeah
yeah I know oh yeah oh it's one of her
other exes amazing Envy Adams would like
you all to come backstage all of us
it's cool how like even the actors were
familiar with are still playing in like
something different they're not just
doing what they normally do you know
even Aubry Plaza it's been a while
I'm Envy I read your Vlog Scott and
Ramona soap average Ramona lived in New
York played the chaos theater for Gideon
you know I'm right I've kissed the lips
that kiss you
oh what the hell just happened
because she kissed Gideon getting that
girl's ex you punch the highlights out
of her hair oh no he punched the
highlights out of her hair foreign
[Music]
you'll pay for your crimes against
humanity
oh no
[Music]
I love this thing with the letterboxes
show we're going into a fight scene
Todd's vegan
oh no it's like an anime character I
partake none of the meat by the breast
milk or the ovum of any creature with a
face short answer being vegan just makes
you better than most people
I was only dating Lucas until the minute
Todd walked by we wreck stuff nobody
cared
he punched a hole in the moon for me
wow a week and a half later he told me
his dad was sending him to vegan Academy
so
exists
basically you can't win this fight so
you're gonna have to give up on this
girl because Todd's gonna kill you you
used to be so nice
oh oh he's gonna use music to win
thank you
[Music]
that's cool film jitters
whoa this guy is undefeatable whoa that
was awesome let's say we drink to my
memory fair trade blend with soy milk
can't drink soy I'll take one soy
thanks to him
oh vegan's country you just drank half
and half baby
speaking police
what the hell
he was worth three thousand Chris Evans
was only worth two thousand that's
surprising well he had super powers it
makes you feel any better you're the
nicest guy I've made wait is that good
it's what I need right now but not later
Scott I don't have all the answers okay
I just like to try and live in a moment
if I can I just like to live
[Music]
ex boyfriend's thing is messing with my
head exes why do you keep saying because
it's not just ex-boyfriends yeah man he
really doesn't know I was just a little
bi-curious well honey
I'm a little five
[Laughter]
[Music]
what's on now
then Gideon best get his pretentious ass
up here cause I'm about to kick yours
out of the great white noise
no way
[Music]
oh wow that's so awesome
this is like brilliantly shot man
seriously
[Music]
it's so Whimsical but cool
damn that was like a really good kick
whoa does she have a Taekwondo
background the precious Scott must
defeat me with his own fists I don't
think I can hit a girl you don't have a
choice
[Music]
hahaha
that's awesome
puppeteering fight
[Music]
she could be coming from anywhere
just fall on her oh damn
was the back of her knees wait how does
that work
[Applause]
what a hard way to go whoa Canada's just
used to murder is there anyone at this
party that you haven't slept with oh oh
okay buddy did you missed the part where
I saved your ass how could I I feel like
we just watched our sexy laundry in
public Dirty Laundry you're drunk had
like wondering
they both lack patience and
understanding I'm on Scott cider about
this though you know PS because you're
stupid
sleep tally twins twins
wow
the battle not only do I want to take
part I want to take them apart I'm
getting tangles
[Laughter]
awesome did you speak to Ramona then
what no she's totally here
guy is she moving on
that
can you hear that oh my God Jason
Schwartzman is he Gideon I don't know he
has to be right
[Music]
it's a band off this looks like an
actual music video
[Music]
whoa Energy washing over the crowd
yes this is a Bohemian affinity
[Music]
oh my goodness
what the hell whoa
[Music]
now it's a monster fight
such vivid expression
[Music]
excuse me
whoa
[Music]
I just can't see your show
oh
she's so sweet poor nice I hate how mean
he is there's okay I hate it so much
what did you want to tell me that we
have to break up I'm back let's get in
now I'm signing you right now for a
three album contract the people need to
hear us Scott well then you're gonna
have to find some there's a caution to
be listen to me
O'Neill
there you go
obviously Scott's a valuable bass player
come on between you and I the whole
league of evil Lexus thing I was in a
really dark place when I put that
together so
forgiven he's the originator of it he's
gonna have to fight Gideon knives is the
only likable yeah person in this world
everyone else is so self-centered
self-serving I don't want any hard
feelings so I figured why not be the
bigger man and just give you a call is
Ramona with you are you with me yeah
[Music]
this pretentious party people you want
to fight me
for her was that not clear because I'm
in love with her what's about to happen
Scott Aaron The Power of Love
if you speak
then
awesome cool smart to use the flash just
so they could disintegrate
the heck it's the ultimate rock and roll
adolescent fantasy
[Music]
I don't know his Love Sword uh oh and I
shall be forced to Grant you a swift
exit from the premises in a fast
entrance into hell
whoa I'm not talking to you I'm talking
to her
you're kidding right
no no she's she's not
whoa
how do they shoot this
[Music]
nobody stole anybody knives I dated you
and then I dated Ramona okay maybe I
forgot to tell knives right away oh my
God he's growing up cheated on both of
us he cheated on me with knives no I
cheated on knives with you right
oh
cheat on these ladies all you like
but you can't
cheat
death oh wow truth is it was me he was
obsessed I was crazy about him
he ignored me I was more alone when we
were together than I ever was on my own
just like with him with knives so I had
to leave so why go back
I can't help myself a random guy he just
it's his way of getting into my head
it's that necklace no I mean he
literally has a way of getting into my
head
oh yeah he is mind controlling so alone
bottle life
literally restarting the level oh my
goodness I love it you want to fight me
for her no I want to fight you for me
Scott earn the power of self-respect
all right
how's it going back there you
didn't disintegrate into coins
no scum this badass hurt you know we'll
have my return no knives I hurt you I
cheated on both of you and you're not a
fat ass
[Music]
really growing up
she's been afraid
[Music]
I love the visuals of it but why are we
having this fight
[Music]
well
oh they have to fight together to get
rid of him
[Music]
I love the way that blade moves
it's a residual wave
[Music]
whoa he's gonna lose the level again
he's ready
cool
nice whoa
I don't know how they did all of this is
just crazy
it's great frenetic style man I'm what's
happening I'm blowing up right now you
are blowing up
whoa so many points like how it's on a
pyramid like you literally conquered the
levels he leveled up can you defeat
yourself
what [__] Scott
let's do it next week yeah yeah all
right be good yeah oh my God he learned
to love himself I said thank you though
for being the nicest guy I ever dated
it's kind of sad
don't get her really she's been fighting
for her all along knives is the best
character
[Music]
I'm too cool for you anyway true mind if
I tag along oh maybe we could try again
how many women have you been with Scott
I don't know if I could deal with that
those are just the guys she dated can
you imagine how many
well well
opening the door and closing new was the
door metaphor metaphor
when you close one door opens
wow that was a fun film I was exhausting
in all the right ways it really was how
do they shoot that that was insane like
I'm like the uh the math that had to go
into shooting this is like in my brain
can't handle it I'm like how how
like especially for the stunts you know
it's not like the over the head shots
even if sure it's a stunt man with a wig
on whatever but still the way the
camera's moving and how many like kicks
and stuff that they do I'm like there's
no way that was in one shot all right no
idea yeah it's it blows my mind also I
loved all the characters I like that
there was still two women in or there
was like three that are just like
deadpan like Aubry Plaza and Kim they're
just like yeah whatever you want to do
which I loved A lot of these like it was
off the cuff people very realistic and
also very hilarious yeah
yeah I loved it wow that that is a brain
frying experience yeah it is a lot of
stimuli coming at you like the whole
time I'm like is it just is it 10
minutes too long in my own head
or is it just been a long day no I think
I think you are right about that like
the fighting could have been at the end
I feel it cut down a little bit when I
got to the second fight with with Jason
Schwartzman I was like do we really need
this right now yeah this is cool and all
but yeah yeah couldn't we have caught to
just him walking out with like his his
whatever his other person I mean other
than that uh yeah I know I mean it's a
yes you know it's been a long day for
Tara but
still really entertaining like I was
really tired before uh when she showed
up I was close my eyes before she showed
up and then yes we were like woke me up
it is a very it is a very dazzling film
yeah a very beautiful one to look at and
very unique on all fronts I love the
amalgamation of feeling like a comic
book but not just like a generic comic
book at times it feels like a manga to
me and then it also has of course the
video game Vibes like they're setting up
all these references and it's got the
um I'll call it Bohemian affinity for
all the kind of music stimuli that you
have throughout the entire film as well
yeah it's it's this is like
um I know this is this is before
baby driver yes that's the one this is
before baby driver but in some ways this
feels more like Edgar Wright incarnate
you know what I mean like it's an
encapsulation of everything that the guy
loves uh in one Big Burrito you know
yeah and I I appreciated it a lot like I
really I really enjoyed it you know I
the thing is sometimes it was actually
helpful that to be here with you because
this it happens with me
when I would get high and then I would
watch a movie like this yeah is why I
couldn't watch animated movies because I
would get so caught up in the visuals
that I couldn't pay attention what the
actors were saying yeah and then
sometimes I would miss a line and you
would you would just repeat it and I'd
be like totally because I'm not even
like on anything right now but even now
I have my misaligner too and then you
were repeatedly oh I didn't even catch
it they said that because so much is
happening and being thrown at you it's
this is crazy cacophony of stuff that's
a cool little video game ending yeah
ending uh pixel three gig that's fun
that's really fun yeah I can't even
think of all the cool lines that I was
saying earlier like what they said
because I can't remember but
um but I loved uh I I loved um uh all
the acting all around like every yeah
every appearance because when they said
seven by the time we defeated Brandon
Routh I was like
oh we still got a few more to go yeah
just a little every time I thought like
is this gonna go on too long right it
kind of a little bit like even with the
twins and the dragon like it could have
been one time they've they they banned
off and then they get them but they had
to go again where it would yeah it felt
a little prolonged
um so I do agree with that like imagine
if there was
15 to 20 minutes cut off this movie
you'd be like this movie's perfect right
because you would have gotten to like
the the heart of it of like him earning
self-respect loving himself and now
um I don't want to have first mistakes
yeah yeah and I guess just like still
ending up with uh
good old flowers but getting the okay
from knives uh was it was sweet I feel
like he didn't need it I thought they
were setting it up for him to end up
with knives until she was like your hair
is getting Shaggy and I was like that's
what Captain Marvel used to say and she
was a botch I think I thought they were
setting him up to end up with nobody
I thought yeah I'd be on his own I think
I would have liked that more right um
that they were just like all right like
see you Scott and then she goes yeah see
Scott and he's just sort of there but
he's like
I'm all right with that cut yeah because
they're young adults but they play it
like they're teenagers in love right and
yeah I thought that when it came to
um Ramona it's still registered to me as
infatuation
because he would still have had these
like dreams of fantasize about her but
right I never really felt like they
never really got to know each other
right
like I like their chemistry together and
I love I like them both a lot as
individual performers and this movie is
more about like mood Vibe style visuals
uh flavor fun comedy action like a lot
of that is the personality of the movie
A lot of that is the K like this is one
of those things where I would say the
style is one of the characters of the
film and yeah and I really love the
journey that that takes you on
um but yeah I think by when I'm just
when I remove that and I just look at
the characters Alone
um yeah you're right yeah
and I thought like a part of this was
the infatuation too but maybe I just
misread it I suppose I would I'm
literally why you're trying while you
were talking trying to think of a line
that happened between him and flowers
that meant more or was more heartfelt of
like them learning about each other or
their right past lives I guess maybe
they just chalked it up to like well
he's learning a lot about her exes and
how she operates but even then it was
still just x's and you gotta you gotta
kill them I mean yes he learned that one
part when he goes You Escape and I get
it
um and that's okay with me that's just a
thing that you've learned remember you
gave her that speech about being like I
get you now and these moves that you're
making sure but you don't necessarily
have to do that with me I think that was
his intention I don't remember the whole
thing guys uh maybe that was the one
part that was the one little heart that
they added in where he finally
understood why she makes then disappears
and stuff and she admits to him why she
does that but other than that we didn't
get much like of them discussing I guess
what you their lives or what they love
or what they hate uh we just it was sort
of just like oh defeat these exes now
sure yeah I mean I like the I like the
Arc of How It's twofold of owning up to
the fact that he cheated not really any
acknowledgment about the whole you know
statutory side of dating right yeah and
the rules are different in Canada
well he never slept with knives
true he only he only maybe he was he was
they didn't even kit or no they kissed
once did they I don't even think they
kissed though no they didn't it was the
one the one time they kissed she
bombarded them at the concert jumped on
him kissed him and it was in front of
flowers and that was that would be
considered their only kiss but they
never did anything other than that
yeah
she's still seven hey man I get it I get
it I was just trying to make it less
creepy by being like well it's like
Michael Sarah is a fine actor and all
but
you know if you look like Ryan Gosling
yeah it's a conversation like oh I get
it yeah and he can get away with
anything he's Ryan Gosling yeah I mean
but then you know he's the guy Michael
Sarah I'm like no it's a register is a
little creepy yeah yeah yeah
before Charming than I'll ever be but uh
yeah I I liked uh I like that I like the
the inclusion the action
because they go right you know he's
known for like the horror that of course
he's in action movies like Hot Fuzz baby
driver a very obvious one yeah
um uh the inclusion of like Kung Fu
mixed with video game type of fighting
actually crazy really well done with
some great blend of like they would have
these one shots when he's fighting all
the stunt doubles where at times it's
obviously Michael Sarah but it'll be one
shot and I'll notice like with the way
the camera moving it moves like an anime
which is a really unique style of like
the certain type of tracking and zooming
going in going out very smoothly and I
was like are there these hidden Cuts
here we're flipping between a stunt
double and stuff and there's a lot of
times you could tell it was actually
Michael Sarah doing the choreography
yeah I mean all that like arm stuff it
was very much him except obviously when
they would cut from up as well yeah
those are like that's a stunt double but
still like
I the whole time I was just thinking wow
how did they do this how did they shoot
this
um
who is your favorite EX
my favorite X in this no real life you
know yeah
I would have just named something some
Miranda like I don't even know
Spider-Man
um
um in here okay favorite x man Chris
Evans is pretty funny and he I don't
know he's he he boarded well is that
what you call it when you're
skateboarder you're like you're a great
boarder man when you said he boarded
well I had no idea what you were
referred to
yes I make up words and stuff
um I guess it would be
I don't know I mean they were all very
entertaining but I did like how like
overly dramatic Chris Evans was yeah he
was the perfect like
80s 90s action star there's a lot of
those like 80s Vibes too as well of of
the kind of like music video expression
of the 80s I would say yeah that would
though with the way they would have a
lot of their dissolves and their
transparency their opaqueness I thought
was really well done as well throughout
yeah yeah that's what I mean it's just
like a whole bunch of the Edgar I love
uh I love Chris Evans I thought Brandon
Ralph was great the vegan guy oh yeah
yeah that's good I like how it made fun
of society a lot and it also was and the
other thing too is like there's so much
genre in here as well when you would cut
between the characters yeah the
different X's there was there was all
these different genres that he was
hitting that like that like you made
that comment of a really strong
character choices with each one of them
they all feel very different yeah
they're all distinct even even like Brie
Larson as well yeah uh feeling like that
old Hollywood Starlet in a way and uh
the the music was also on like Edgar
Wright which was in the soundtracks very
great too
um but the original scores as well very
strong I like that the music of just the
bands the bands were there yeah normally
they were sometimes you could really
mess that up and it was really great it
was good I specifically like Brie Larson
song I think the most I was early
jamming out I see why she was the one
who became famous Karen Culkin was
really fun too I love it so much
oh my goodness he's uh he just has a
soft spot in my heart he's such a good
actor
um I feel like we've touched on all the
main stuff have we covered it have we
touched on it have we covered everything
my brain is like like uh we're both
alone
very grateful there's very bright lights
in this room right now because they're
keeping me awake otherwise I feel like
I'd be asleep on the ground right it's
been a long day uh well I think we
covered it we like the thing I mean
Scott we we've still felt like Scott was
a little bit of a jerk throughout it but
so is everyone out everyone else was
mean to everyone like it was a lot of
[__] giving in this which I am great at
so I understood it it didn't bug me that
much I didn't register in my brain that
like oh they're all jerks because like I
give [__] to my friends all the time
um but when once you said that and then
how like awkward it was the way he
treated knives and you felt so bad for
her they did paint him in a light where
I was like oh come on man I thought at
some point he was just gonna be nice to
her and be like hey I'm sorry for like
me being me I'm a douche I whatever but
that didn't happen he did do it with Kim
though true which was nice like he he
had moments where he redeemed himself at
the end and then you realize kind of
that it was a self-love self-respect
thing that was ruining the the entire
time well yeah I mean that that was part
of the journey as yeah he was going like
oh he people who don't love themselves
or respect themselves will treat others
like [__] or if you got their pain and
on others so yeah no there's like some
nuanced stuff here and it also knows
when it's being
pretentious to the point where they'll
acknowledge it like oh I feel like I
learned something here you know and and
I think that this there's a good
self-awareness about it to do it in a
comical way but also be just deep enough
where it's not overly in your face not
not overt enough uh yeah yeah the Blends
were good Mary Elizabeth Winstead saw
her performance she's typical she's got
that that indie girl Vibe yeah that is
like the kind of person in an indie
movie A zoidation now yeah exactly yeah
yeah those are the two characters I
often refer to when I sit with an agent
I'm like uh the roles that those ladies
plays what I would fit into these are
the genres and the movies that I want to
be in
they're great they're great it was great
I love that he loved it we loved it all
and we love you too so tell us if you
loved it in the comments
yeah I think we close it out do we go
how do I with a patron shout out
[Music]
all right so we are gonna do uh do it
Andrew Hayes oh Hayes Andrew hey hey
might be a short stocky white boy from
Jersey but he's in love with Tara oh my
gosh and you know what he's gonna have
to do Sarah who Tara me Tara Erickson oh
my God Hayes Hayes likes he's gonna
happen you're gonna have to to fight all
my ex fight all of the X's there's
75. my God the number here how do you
not have that Jesus that's a large
number oh I'm like a squat you know
sometimes we'd hold hands for like six
months and you know how they get upset
when I'm like I think we should stop
holding hands doesn't matter Andrews is
gonna have to beat all them up you're
gonna have to be I'm talking Bronco
remember Bronco Bronco was your first
true love tell them about Bronco that
you have to beat up oh Bronco uh Bronco
uh yeah I mean I liked him he got me
like a Winnie the Pooh uh stuffed animal
in like seventh grade sweet guy and he
took me like in the go-karts once and I
like that yeah so when I think back on
it no one else has done that for me so I
get real sad that's why he's the worst
one Broncos sounds like you should get
back
if you see this video I miss you hey
Bronco She Loves You Bronco yeah she
loves you and not as much as Andrew does
and apparently Andrew loves me a lot
more why are you trying to get in the
way Andrew when it's clearly a hot
doesn't belong to you come on well I
mean he could come in here too I could I
could just
see if it works with me with Andrew oh
yeah maybe you can have both go you
could do both you know why not
those dating apps
that goes on the west coast no problemo
oh my God just fly back and forth
foreign